interroger nos concitoyens c'est
toujours une bonne chose euh est-ce que
sur un sujet aussi difficile que
celui-là on peut trouver la bonne
question qui permettent de répondre
euh de répondre vraiment à un sujet qui
est je je le redis qui touche à l'intime
de chacun et qui est vraiment très
compliqué pour avoir beaucoup travaillé
sur le sujet je le redis avoir travaillé
avec des soignants avec des
parlementaire avoir beaucoup consulté
c'est un sujet qui est vraiment très
très compliqué et on voit bien que la
question du OUI ou du non sur un sujet
comme celui-là si la question c'est
est-ce que il faut que la loi évolue sur
la fin de vie mais après je je je et là
c'est pour ça que c'est difficile aussi
de de de sur le modèle choisi on voit
bien d'ailleurs que autour de nous il y
a différents modèles choisi par
différents pays donc ça dépend vraiment
de la question sur un sujet comme
celui-là je la question à poser à
répondre par oui ou par non n'est pas si
simple que ça est-ce que on parle juste
d'une évolution du CP de du du principe
parce que c'est c'est un sujet de
société c'est clairement un sujet de
société et les nombreux débats que je
fais auxquels je participe et encore et
je vais encore en continuer à faire vois
bien me montre à quel point je crois que
la société est vraiment pas à évoluer
mais tout le monde s'interroge et c'est
légitime qu' excusez-moi mais pour pour
résumer votre positionnement c'est
réticence vis-à-vis du référendum du
fait de la difficulté de la question en
en elle-même donc plutôt privilégier le
débat parlementaire je crois ouais sur
un sujet comme celui-là vraiment c'est
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment très très
compliqué hein euh par parce que on voit
bien et et le débat parlementaire aussi
permettra d'enrichir le texte c'est le
rôle des parlementaire euh et pourtant
le président continue le travail juste
pardon avec les groupes parlementaires
ça vous continue je pas revu depuis
depuis on va continuer le travail bien
sûr pardon Julien non mais pourtant le
le le président va va proposer cette
réflexion à aux rencontres de
Saint-Denis demain l'ouverture du du du
champ du référendum peut-être sur la
question de la fin de sur les non
peut-être sur les questions de société
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
la fin la fin de vie la fin de vie fait
partie des questions de société jeique
moi je suis pas contre le principe la
difficulté sur un sujet comme celui-là
c'est qu'on voit bien que on ne peut pas
répondre à la question uniquement par
est-ce que vous voulez l'euthanasie ou
est-ce que vous voulez le subs assisteré
franchement je pour avoir beaucoup
travaillé le sujet c'est pas si simple
que
ça